♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU WANT A FEEL-GOOD
STORY FOR TODAY?
IMAGINE TRYING TO TRACK DOWN THE
HACKER WHO TRIED TO POISON A
TAMPA BAY WATER SUPPLY BY TAKING
OVER CONTROL OF A COMPUTER
SYSTEM’S MOUSE.
DID I SAY "FEEL-GOOD?
"I LIED BECAUSE IT IS ACTUALLY A
LIE.
THE ACTION INCREASED SODIUM
HYDROXIDE, THAT’S LYE, TO 100
PER MILLION.
LYE IS WHAT YOU FIND IN DRAIN
CLEANERS.
SPRINKLE LYE ON A DEAD HORSE AND
YOU GET SO.
CNN SPRINKLES IT ON TRUTH AND
CALLS AT PRIME TIME.
IF WE KNOW ONE THING ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE MEDIA IT IS
THAT THEY CAN DO TWO THINGS AT
ONCE.
THEY CAN BARELY DO ONE THING AT
YOU’VE GOT JOURNALIST CHASING
DOWN PROBLEMATIC PHRASES INSTEAD
OF ACTUAL DANGER.
MEANWHILE, IMPEACHMENT PART TWO
IS DESIGNED TO PLEASE REPORTERS
AND DEMS ALIKE BECAUSE THEY ARE
LIKE.
IT WON’T RESULT IN ANYTHING
EXCEPT ELATED COVID RELIEF AND
HAVE DEMOCRATS MUMBLING AT
PODIUMS.
WE’VE SEEN IT BEFORE.
AS REAL THREATS MOTOR ON.
WE NEED THAT 20 YEARS AGO AS WE
CHASED THE GARY -- CASE AND
OBSESSED OVER BILL CLINTON’S
INFIDELITIES, AL QAEDA HAD OTHER
PLANS.
THE WORLD DOESN’T STOP FOR OUR
PATHETIC NEW CYCLES.
THE WORLD TAKES ADVANTAGE OF OUR
MEDIA AND OUR POLITICIANS.
WE WERE WARNED ABOUT THE WATER
SUPPLY BEFORE.
MAYBE IT’S NOT A HACK BUT IN
ERROR, BUT I’M NO EXPERT.
I AM IN THE MEDIA.
BUT I’M WILLING TO BET NOT A
SINGLE DEMOCRAT CARE AS MUCH
THERE IS A CIRCUS IN TOWN AND
THEY ARE IN BOX SEATS LOADING UP
ON COTTON CANDY, POPCORN AND
LYE.
LET’S HOPE THEY DON’T DRINK THE
WATER.
DANNA, HERE’S THE DEAL.
I’M A LITTLE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
CERTAIN THINGS.
THIS BOTHERS ME BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE WATER SUPPLY IS A TARGET BUT
WHENEVER SOMEBODY SAYS HACK, IT
ALWAYS TURNS OUT TO BE A
MISTAKE, THAT SOMEBODY HIT THE
BUTTON.
REMEMBER THE MISSILES SCARE IN
HAWAII, OR ANTHONY WEINER?
IT’S ALWAYS A HACKER.
I MEAN, IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS A HACKER?
>> Dana: I THINK IT IS
POSSIBLE.
REMEMBER THE OTHER STORY THAT
DIDN’T GET A LOT OF ATTENTION
EARLY LAST MONTH WAS THAT OF THE
SOLAR WIND HACK INTO NOT ONLY
BIG CORPORATIONS IN AMERICA BUT
ALL ACROSS OUR GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT, COMMERCE DEPARTMENT
AND THEY WERE IN THERE FOR
MONTHS AND STILL MIGHT BE IN
THERE AND THERE HAS ACTUALLY NOT
BEEN ENOUGH REPORTING ON THAT OR
BASICALLY ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
FAILURE OF OUR GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT US ALL FROM THAT.
SO THERE’S THAT PIECE OF IT.
THAT STORY, YOU WERE THE FIRST
PERSON I THOUGHT OF, GREG.
NOT BECAUSE I THOUGHT YOU WERE A
HACKER BUT BECAUSE TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN WE STARTED "THE FIVE," YOU
KEPT TALKING ABOUT IT BEING A
SOFT TARGET AND HOW TECHNOLOGY
AND TERRORISM, WHEREVER IT WAS
COMING FROM, APPARENTLY THEY
DON’T EVEN KNOW IF THIS CAME
FROM IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
OUTSIDER EVEN IF IT WAS A HACK
TO YOUR POINT, BUT YOU WERE THE
FIRST PERSON I THOUGHT OF
BECAUSE I THOUGHT, GREG HAS BEEN
TRYING TO WARN EVERYBODY ABOUT
THIS VERY THING.
>> Jesse: YEAH, WHEN I THINK
OF SOFT TARGETS I THINK OF
GREG GUTFELD.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
THIS ATTACK IS MOSTLY PEACEFUL,
RIGHT?
>> Jesse: I DON’T REMEMBER
MUCH FROM CHEMISTRY BUT I DO
REMEMBER THAT WATER IS THE
SOURCE OF LIFE AND CIVILIZATION.
AND IF YOU GO AFTER THE WATER
SOURCE, THAT’S LIKE PULLING OUT
THE WRONG JANGO PIECE IN A TOWER
KABOOM, IT ALL COMES CRASHING
DOWN.
IF THIS IS SUCCESSFUL YOU ARE
LOOKING AT A MASS CASUALTY
TERROR ATTACK.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THIS LIKE A RED FLAG AND PROMOTE
WHOEVER OUR CYBER WARFARE GUYS
ARE, MAKE THEM THEIR OWN
MILITARY BRANCH LIKE THE SPACE
FOR US.
GIVE THEM THEIR OWN UNIFORMS
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU THIS IS
THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE.
I’M NOT AFRAID OF MISSILES
ANYMORE.
I’M AFRAID OF HACKERS, AND I’M
NOT AFRAID OF MUCH.
>> Greg: I DON’T WANT ANY LYE
GETTING ON YOU, WATTERS.
JUAN, IT SEEMS THAT WE HAVE
MOVED AWAY FROM THE TRADITIONAL
VIEW OF WAR AND IF YOU MARRY A
DRONE WITH A PACKET OF LYE, HOW
EASY IS THAT TO JUST FLY A DRONE
OVER A RESERVOIR?
YOU DON’T NEED TO HACK.
>> Juan: YEAH, I JUST WANT TO
UNDERLINE HOW EXPENSIVE, SOLAR
WINDS, THERE’VE BEEN HACKS OF
SOFTWARE, READ SOMEWHERE, SO
RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE
CYBERCRIME MAY BE THE MOST --
CRIME AFFECTING AMERICA BECAUSE
IT’S JUST EVERYWHERE AND PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE HACKERS BUT A
HACKER IS AN ACTUAL PRESENT AND
MAYBE THEY’RE WORKING FOR
SOMEBODY BUT THEY’VE GOT TO
ARREST, PROSECUTE, GO AFTER
THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE WHEN
THEY’RE GOING AFTER WATER SUPPLY
THAT MEANS THEY’RE TRYING TO
KILL US.
>> Greg: YEP.
ANYWAY, JUDGE, I WAS GOING TO
SAY A JOKE THAT JESSE TOLD ME
THIS MORNING BUT I DECIDED NOT
TO USE IT BECAUSE I’M THINKING
DIFFERENTLY NOW.
IT JUDGE, THIS IS WHY I’M GOING
TO START DRINKING CANNED BEER
INSTEAD OF WATER.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE BECAUSE ALL CRIMES
ARE BEING COMMITTED IN NEW WAYS,
AND I REALIZE THIS ONE,
CYBERCRIME IS PROBABLY THE
NUMBER ONE CRIME THAT AFFECTS
AMERICANS MORE THAN ANY OTHER.
THE HARDENING OF THE GRID AND
THE HARDENING OF ANYTHING THAT
PROTECTS OUR WATER SUPPLY IS
ESSENTIAL, AND SHAME ON US IF WE
DON’T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
WARNINGS AND THERE IS A LOT TO
LOSE IN THIS WORLD WHERE AMERICA